simple undeniable example is nice guys
finish
last
that one let's do that before we go nice
guys finish last
um
you you have this is all you in it
do you guys know these emails i know
it's easy okay so i was oh yeah i'd done
a zz mills interview i would i've done a
conversation with these emails right
yeah and she said specifically
yeah
that women
look for guys
who have a quote-unquote
edge
that's what she said an edge whatever
that edge is
right so she was saying when it comes to
nice guys nice guys don't have that
quote unquote edge
right which is why they finished last
because women generally want a man
with an edge because it's new is it
because it's new i think whatever that
edge is
it could be someone who that's why a lot
of the quote-unquote pookies and
ray-rays and road guys get a lot of
girls because they got a quote-unquote
edge
right the other guys don't so is that
true do women look for a man with an
edge i think for me personally i look
for someone with confidence if you have
a con confident aura like an assertive
or it doesn't it doesn't always have to
be like okay you tell me what to do or
you put me in my place no it's like but
you did say that before though because
you said you wanted a man that can
overpower your masculinity yeah through
his assertiveness or confidence i'm
saying but i'm saying it doesn't always
have to be that it's an energy that i
can feel if you come to me and say okay
cool
i can i can feel the confidence i can i
don't mind you being nice but a lot of
the times the nice guys
don't always have that
full confidence or they all don't always
have that assertiveness where you can
yeah so you're saying that men need to
be like
edgy just to get away with that but
would that wouldn't that be your edge
then i guess yeah i'll say i'll say from
my perspective yeah what has been your
experience do you think that the men
with quote unquote edge get the girls
it's true they do because they
they did like the way they handled the i
call it sauce in it the way they handle
the sauce is different if you're just a
typical guy like average joe then you're
not going to get that kind of exposure
to women in it if you're different with
it
then you will
you know i mean that's what girls like
so imagine the majority of women now
let's say 80 percent are looking for the
guy with the quantum core edge
right
the guy with the quote-unquote edge
probably could be like fake percent of
men
so 30 of men
are now getting 80 of women
and there's a whole seventy percent of
men like
what about me
do you get what i'm saying and that's
why they do that's why they do to get
them courses from andrew tate
and all them things there because they
wanna
because they they're trying to get that
sound like pick me men there you go is
that what it is pick me men it's pick me
men yeah but like the other thing you've
got to take into account oh john i
forgot but i'll come back okay no so
yeah like the majority of women are
looking for the minority of men
they want the special type so if the
majority of women are looking for the
minority of men
those minority of men no they got the
majority of women to pick from which is
why the minority of women are fighting
over so the majority of women are
fighting over the minorities
yeah and that's why women think men are
trash that's right because you're
looking at the trash man that have
multiple options which is why when men
tend to breed they tend to breed of
multiple women because they can because
those are the women looking for them
yeah the other thing you take into
account is nice guys will tend to
exhibit traits that they're not able to
be aggressive because they're trying to
show a nice side of them and
aggression in itself uh is a
characteristic that women find
attractive that's right like i said they
want to watch a man fight so they'll
look a woman will look at a nice guy and
go um he couldn't
protect me he couldn't protect me if
needed to he couldn't turn off the jets
if needed to so therefore the attraction
for that nice guy isn't there
and then you find those women who
tend to try and turn up the jets on the
man to see if he can
and men get thinking oh my god i need to
be more manly and get themselves into
some
dumbass trouble how many men are sitting
down in prison because they wanted to
impress a woman because he wants to turn
on the jets
right how many men are now dead because
of women because you want to turn on the
jets in front of them because they
wouldn't be impressed i'm telling men
stop that [ __ ]
okay stop it start being yourself and
stop getting yourself into trouble okay
because of women okay
hang on a lot of the time women will
lead you down a path because when you're
in prison
they're outside having sex with your
best friend they're not waiting on you
bro why they're not waiting on you okay
stop it they're calling you on the phone
thinking that you're the one no that's
what we call i say that's dying for
nyash
no it's not worth it they said it best
there you go
they said it was santander shout out to
him you were gonna say something though
i was gonna say so okay so for the men
who are watching this and who are who
feel like they are in that category how
do you recommend they approach women um
oh we had that conversation last time oh
okay we were saying um no that's fine we
were saying um women were saying there's
a time to approach women
and it's not at two o'clock at night
time oh i agree right i agree however if
you're the right man there's no wrong
time to approach a woman there you go
right you're saying the right time a lot
of men don't know how to approach women
which is why a lot of men when they do
approach women come off as a little bit
creepy
right because they've probably geared
themselves up
in their head thinking oh my god i've
been looking at someone for so long
they don't know how to do it so when
they when it happens we were like
what's this guy doing right how to
approach a woman
how i approach her i can only look at me
like me
um i look at her
and i find something on her as a woman
that i know she'll be appreciative of
so if for instance if i'm going to
approach them like you know what your
nails are really getting your nose done
that's all i'm saying guys
that's what we call games okay we call
that game
out
find what a woman you know a woman likes
yeah and compliment on her or compliment
her on it or even ask a question about
it it's just it's a shoe in the door
it's not showing
it's a study you have to learn you have
to learn these things okay quick little
question i don't know if it will be
quick but um
okay so we're talking about masculine
and feminine energies what do you guys
think about women shooting the shot
you're going going mate you're going to
ask me i can't lie
as me i don't mind that
i think
it sure it attracts me because it shows
me what you want in that moment of time
even so even so it takes away
my masculinity
i
i will do i do my best to insert my
masculinity when you have shot your
moment
do you know i find with women that shoot
their shot with me go on um
they're not forthright
they start saying certain things
oh do you know what
yeah i watched one of your videos it was
really good actually you know
let me tell you something i'm smart
enough to know that if you're saying
that to me and you're in my dms that's
that's you trying to that's what we call
peacocking right okay you're trying to
you're trying to
fan out you're trying to show me how
great you are
without saying
what you want to actually say so you
want me
to now
come to you after you've made the move
but the move you're making is very
subtle and i feel like when women shoot
their shot it's very subtle
generally still waiting for you they're
still waiting for you to shoot the shot
after they just kind of just through the
ball there you go take the ball like
just shoot the shots you know what i
mean i feel like women in general don't
want to shoot their shot properly
because they're scared of rejection
when a woman decides that this is the
man that they want
they have if a what if because men are
used to rejection
men get rejected all the time because
i've been in a position where where
girls shoot the shot but i guess my
question is properly shoot their shot
like like oh my god you're so nice
what's your name yes yeah yeah i've been
in that position really i know
i will i'll show them the same energy
from that but my question is would you
actually take that person seriously
because we're here talking about
masculine energy is how you want to
approach that is that a little bit too
masculine do you see that woman as
somebody i don't see it as masculine i
see it as go on jenna so i was literally
about to answer this so i was speaking
to my uh
cousins and brothers about this and i
was saying that as a man uh you have the
mindset of a hunter and essentially if
your prey came up to you
asking
yeah come and eat me it'd be it's kind
of repulsive and it's like put barbecue
sauce on himself and we're like look i'm
tasty what then happens is when you have
girls approaching you moving to you
right
yeah you might smash on everything but
you're not going to take them seriously
as candidates because you didn't pick
them
you didn't select them you weren't the
person that said this is mine i want
this that was the question i was going
to ask you exactly
so
what if you're used to that
if you're used to that it's fine like
you you're going to get that attention
yeah that's what it is as a man if
you're used to that women shooting a
shot yeah
it's probably because you're in your
feminine
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm just saying i'm
the reason why i'm saying that
is because
because generally when a man is in his
quote-unquote masculine women see it and
they admire it but i journeyed because
they're a little bit it's a little bit
like oh should i talk to him oh my god
should i speak to that guy
what i should do is just let him know
i'm in the vicinity
i'll let him know that i'm in the
vicinity right so i'll just make little
i don't know little i don't know
moves or
gestures to make him know i'm there but
i'm definitely not going to shoot my
shot at him
ladies don't shoot your shot i've been
saying this thank you i'm not trying to
disrespect you bro no no no i get
i'm really not bro i'm not i'm not i'm
just saying like
women that are in their feminine
generally
don't really shoot their shot
but but the thing is like i said before
i feel like men have become more and
it's not a disrespect a lot of men have
become a little bit more feminine and
women have become a little bit more
masculine
and so
that whole city girls
cardi b generation yeah always talking
about
their whap yeah
do you know what i'm saying like that
kind of generation is like look at my
team look at this
it's that's now that that's now how
women kind of shoot their shot because
once you show people what you've got
men are going to be like oh oh damn
that's what you got
i shoot my shot as a guy but
it does happen sometimes like
it will happen that someone will take
the initiative to come now it's happened
to me yeah it's it's actually happened
to me as a man like and i've been like
do you know what like i said before
masculine women men will definitely have
sex with them yeah listen because a
masculine woman can be dressed in her
most feminine
do you know what i'm saying she could be
dressed like oh my god she looks amazing
but her energy is masculine right right
and a man will definitely have sex with
her but is he going to go
to go to the next level that's going to
be a problem yeah
that's going to be
it's going to be a problem